welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast i'm your
host
hisham azuz and this week's episode is a
fantastic one i was joined by ethan hall
from interx who over the last seven
eight years has gone from being the
first employee in the business to now
director and shareholder he's always
been in contract recruitment and every
single year he has leveled up his
performance it's been tough it's been
challenging which we absolutely talk
about in this episode but we also talk
about how he was able to break 1.5
million in billings last year and how
he's even broken that record already
this year ethan is someone that's
inspirational hard-working and i'm so
excited for all of you to learn from
ethan's journey so far
enjoy
ethan welcome to the podcast thanks for
having me pleasure to be here
really excited for this one i'll
probably say that for for most uh
episodes but uh having having sat down
with jamie uh previously um and now
she's sitting down with you one of the
success stories of interx being his
first hire
being
the top performer i know a lot of people
are going to be very interested in how
you got there the challenges along the
way
and what you had to work through but
what we always like to start with
and what i'd love to get your sort of
take on is from your perspective and
your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you believe make up a highly
successful high performing recruitment
concern in today's market
well one intro thanks for that um yeah i
think there's quite a lot of traits i
don't think there's like one single word
you can explain to
of why someone will be super successful
um
it's such a competitive market nowadays
but i think in my case i
i believe the reason why i've been quite
successful is that i've been very
obsessive
um i just become obsessed with
doing deals
reaching the next target and being
obsessed with that winning mentality um
and i've always been super disciplined
even from a young age i've been very
focused on what i want to achieve
so yeah i think from my case it's always
been obsessive i've been disciplined
i've always been a hard worker um i've
always been in early been late um really
putting in the effort and i think
being consistent doing that over the
years i think that's why it's led me to
be personal i am today really
and uh those are things the
obsessiveness the persistent discipline
are those are things that you think will
enable people to
achieve their goals get to where they
want to still in like today's market
because it would have changed a lot
since your last six seven eight years in
the industry yeah massively um
i've never really sort of believed that
natural talent is good right of course
but i think
you haven't always got to be the best
salesman for this job um
i i do believe recruitment is a massive
mind game i think it's a massive test on
mentality and i feel like
coming into recruitment as long as
you've got the right mindset and the
mentality to to want to succeed that
beats talent i think you know when
people are lazy but they're talented
and someone who's less talented but
works harder will always outperform that
person and i think that's quite clear in
recruitment yeah mindset's huge for sure
so
for me i really want to sort of really
get into the weeds of like the last six
years obviously it was six years of
interest august just gone you're telling
me earlier uh but i guess let's just
touch on because i know before you
joined interx
you had highs and lows right and it
wasn't all plain salem so i guess what
what i'd just love you to share with us
is
how would you
how would you describe even before
recruitment
yeah definitely not the man i am today
um i mean yeah growing up i was i wasn't
the best student
i was always messing around in school i
wasn't very academic
i just had no interest in going down
that route going to college going to uni
wasn't really my thing
i started work at 15 so i was in the
office on the phones at 15 selling so
straight away i was i was on the phone
wanting to make money and work hard
so
yeah i think
it took me a long time to kind of adapt
to the working environment
and taking my career seriously
um
so i think yeah leading up to
recruitment i wasn't i wasn't the best
student i wasn't the best kind of worker
um but then when i got into recruitment
at the age of 17
the reality hit and it really hit home
and that's when i really started to sort
of adapt and grow up really
where do you think you mentioned earlier
around the importance of persistence
obsession work ethic
where do you think you got that from
yeah
it's a hard question because um
of course i've got quite a supportive
family and they've always kind of you
know wanted me to do well but i've
always kind of
knew i was going to be successful i just
kind of had a feeling that i was going
to do well um i didn't know what in but
i just knew i wanted to to be somewhere
so
i've always been very self-confident not
arrogant i've been very self-confident
in my abilities and knowing that i'm
going to get somewhere
so
i think with me i've always looked at
people and thought well
if you can do it i can do it you know
we're all born the same way we've all
got the same dna you know the same
genetic makeup so i thought
if he can do it i can do it surely so
i've always looked at other people in
many industries and felt right okay you
know
i can see part of me and you so i think
i can do it so i've always kind of had
that mentality and i've never really
kind of given up so i think that's why
i've really wanted to
just carry on in recruitment and and do
what i do best really i love that
so
let's like i'd love you just to share
with us because we're just getting to
know each other before we started this
like a lot of people uh counted you out
in recruitment definitely right what is
it like you got let go from what free
was it free companies before yeah
decided to join jamie yeah
embarrassingly yeah but obviously so a
lot of people
yeah uh counted you out what what was it
that you think i don't know i guess what
i'm trying to ask is what was it that
you think
um was different about what you've ended
up doing in the last six years
that didn't sort of manifest in these
other other environments because i think
we were saying before right that a lot
of people can enter the recruitment
industry work for one company it doesn't
work out and then they're like oh wow
recruitment's not for me and we can lose
a lot of sort of potential great talent
in our industry due to that but you
persevered you carried on despite yeah
having those uh knockbacks and and that
rejection and then you've then built
this successful career in the last six
years
so what i don't know if looking back
what were some of the
the key things maybe that uh you think
had a real influence on you actually
building a successful career rather than
the previous companies and obviously
there's circumstantial stuff but yeah
looking back that you think really i
don't know influenced these last six
years
um i think
i think joining recruitment at a very
young age has definitely got something
to do with it i mean i was like newly 17
when i started in recruitment so i've
still got my kind of school boy
attitude mentality and that was a hard
thing to shake off um i had a bit of an
attitude when i was younger
and
i think coming into recruitment i sort
of saw it as like fun and games even i
wanted to make money and succeed and do
well i just really
yeah i just didn't really sort of take
it too seriously and
i think carrying a kind of attitude in
that kind of mindset it definitely sets
you back a few paces
but i think the reason why things
started to change was because first of
all i had a good mentor i think having a
good mentoring recruitment is so
important um
i don't think you know no matter how
talented you are how hard work and you
are how disciplined if you haven't got a
good mentor
it's very difficult to to make it
through in your recruitment career so i
had someone there to support me
um but at the same time finding the kind
of right kind of culture
the right people to work with you know
and then actually working with people
that
actually are successful
there's a lot of people in recruitment
where you know
they're kind of working like they've got
a nine-to-five mentality
you know they're just happy getting the
paycheck you know their life is very
just it's not really
moving forward in the right direction
and
when you're working around people that
aren't really succeeding in recruitment
the reality seems very far away because
if you're looking at people that aren't
really successful you're thinking well
okay
i've got no one to compare to i've got
no one to compete against so
naturally when you're in that
environment i think it makes you take a
step back
so the moment you go into an environment
where you're working with high
performers and people that are really
successful
you want to drive towards that um and i
think that was a big part of it for me i
was in the right culture the right
environment i had a good mentor
and then a light bulb kind of switched
and thought right okay like i need to
switch on here i need to make slanker
myself because i've got no education to
fall back onto i've got no plan b like
this is it i need to make sure i switch
on and that's what really happened to be
fair so just on that i think would be
helpful for people before we unpack this
journey like
with you going on the things you're
saying sharing that around like the
culture the people that you can learn
from
actually it being a really high
performance
environment
what would your advice be to people uh
who at the moment are interviewing at
different companies or are looking at
different recruitment companies what
would you say to them that you think
would be good advice to help them
identify the the right types of cultures
that they want to be part of i think you
can only sometimes gauge so much in the
interview environment you know what i
mean so i feel like for people a big
part of it it can be overwhelming
there's so many recruitment companies so
thinking with what you know now and like
how impactful that's been what would you
say to people that could be good advice
on trying to find out like in that
interview environment maybe good
questions or things to make sure you
always ask that's going to give them
more confidence that they're going to
end up in the culture that's going to
enable them to thrive
yeah i think what people need to bear in
mind you're talking to sales people when
you're going into interview right so
they're always going to sell you a dream
um but
being
on both sides of the table
um it's so important that you know when
you are going to a company and they are
selling you that dream you really need
to push on that you know why is it going
to be a dream um you know what what are
the benefits why am i going to do well
here so
you know when you're talking to these
people in the interview in a way you
need to interview them you need to
interview the company you know you want
to be you want to talk to the top
builder
you want to find out what numbers he's
doing why is he doing those numbers
is there room for someone else to do
those numbers um and then you also want
to find out about what the middle
consultants are doing i'd always want to
find out okay what are they billing what
market are they doing okay is there room
for me to build in that market um and
then you want to understand who you're
gonna work with potentially because
me personally if i was working with
someone who was only a billion
hundred two hundred for underground a
year i don't want to work with someone
like that because you know
if i'm going to be learning from someone
like that with the ability to only build
those numbers
it's not enough you know i want to i
want to learn from the best so
understanding who you're going to work
with you want to understand okay
what kind of training they got in place
that is so key because there's so many
companies where
you know you're going to do one or two
weeks of training and then right that's
it you're left in the deep end you want
to understand okay what is the training
course how long does it go on for what
you cover
um is it continuous support or is it
just two weeks and that's it um you
really will understand how deep their
development is
um and you will understand where you can
move in the company is there progression
um and then of course you want to find
about the culture right you want to find
out
what are their interests you know what
incentives have they got and that's
going to be really important i think
it's so important to speak to as many
people in the company so make sure you
get a good feel for the business such
good advice i love that so let's unpack
this journey mate so i'm help me out
here if i've missed any key stuff but i
know
i'm prepping for this i think what's
always helpful is let's just give
people listening some context as like
where you are today
and then we're going to talk about
the challenges and the hardships that
you had to go through to get there but i
think this uh obviously would just be a
good um perspective for people so
i've sat down with jamie uh previously
uh who's obviously the founder of the
company and he was yeah your boss and
you were his first hire and you're now
obviously pushing on circus 17 plus
people so you've been on that whole
journey in terms of whereas a business
today and you've also got uh obviously a
office in the uk and um miami obviously
you've always done contract right always
and
you've i i feel like one of the great
things that jamie and you guys have done
is you've been very niche and very
focused so your market correctly from
wrong is microsoft dynamics right yep
yes you've been very focused on that
always done contract uh and then
obviously at them um in the the last
year or however you do it you were the
the top performer and your best year so
far has been 1.5 million billions wise
right and then from a contract
perspective i think you said the highest
point was your sort of weekly gp was
running a 40k mark and that sort of
circle around 70 contractors and runners
yeah so that was that was last year's
last year last year's number were we in
like what the eighth month for this year
did you do january to december or what's
your no we do uh january to december so
we did the full year yeah so like yeah
like you said you're on track to
hopefully
beat that from last year right oh yeah
yeah so um i've i've already kind of
beat that already really yeah yeah so um
yeah so at the moment um i'm on track to
doing two million pound this year okay
um yeah my contract book at the moment
is sitting about
58 i'm going on 60 car a week
i'm pushing about 90 contractors now so
the growth is still there at the moment
so that's where we are today as we are
today people going how the [ __ ] is done
there yeah that's crazy right even i
can't believe i've done it yeah so okay
cool so that i hope that's helpful for
people of like right this is this is
where you are today so i guess
i guess firstly like
let's just just go straight into like
some of the like really challenging
periods that you've really had to sort
of work through overcome that's then
enabled in the long run for you to get
to this position so let's just start
with before i say to you like looking in
this sort of six year journey what what
were some of the like the lowest moments
that you really had to push through what
were some of the most challenging times
where you might have doubted yourself
you might i don't think actually i'm
going to be able to carry on do this or
am i
going to be able to achieve the goals i
think i can like what were some of the
most most challenging periods for you on
this journey so far
there's been a lot there really has i
mean i've been through it literally
multiple times
so i think for me the one of the most
challenging things for me was
i've literally
seen my contract book you know
plummet overnight
literally going into december having a
blood bath where you know
contract book was i think at one point
like 15k a week it dropped down to like
under 6k a week so my earnings like more
than half it was like terrible
um
that's happened twice twice i've had
that and when when was that and like if
you can remember roughly
yeah so this was about um
not the particular month but i guess was
it in like the first two three years was
it has it been in the last it was about
i think two or three years ago yeah two
three years ago it happens um yeah i
think my third third and fourth year
happened twice twice wow yeah um and
that was pretty hard to deal with
because when you're a contract recruiter
you get so fixated on getting to the
next milestone it's like get to 10k it's
15kg 20k
and that requires so much effort
and when it gets taken away from you
overnight like that
it's like it's demoralizing other things
you can't control can't control it it's
just okay right budget is getting cut
products ending
whatever reason noms getting extended
and it's just like
when that happens it's like you realize
the graft you've got to put back into it
and it's hard um
and
i remember when that happened at one
point i thought
i don't think i can do this again i
thought i don't know
yeah like going from like under 6k a
week back up to 15k a week i'm thinking
i don't think i can do this this is this
is gonna be hard work and
having that mental struggle to
to get the drive and the hunger to do it
again
was hard um but when it happened the
second time i thought you've done it
before you can do it again so let's
think about that first time then for a
second yeah i think that could be really
relatable for people
like how was your feeling what did like
what did you do to try and snap out of
it because you like you said you could
have gone can i do it again you could
have gone i don't think i wanna carry on
with this yeah so like
how
you could that could just put you in a
funk for however
however long how did you like deal with
that did you i don't know how to go out
for a walk did you go straight down to
the pub like how did you actually like
deal with it and go and sort of come to
the realization of like you know what
i'm gonna crack on and and do this again
yeah don't get me wrong like i was i was
low for at least a week i'm thinking
like yeah my head was all over the gap i
didn't know what to do
um
i was thinking right okay
is recruitment right for me am i really
going to get the life i want to get from
this you know i've put all the hard work
in why has this happened to me
all these thoughts are going from my
head
um and
it took me about yeah at least a week to
get my head straight it really did um
i had a few conversations with jamie and
i was like okay look like this is really
[ __ ]
what can i do
um he gave me the support it's happened
to jamie before you know overnight your
book's down it's happened to him before
so
leaning on him getting advice from him
thinking what i can do
going back to the basics starting over
again setting a plan and going at it
um
and that that was really you know
what what the focus was i take a week
you know get over it cry about whatever
you need to do but then once you've done
that you need to get a plan in place and
go out again because
it's a cliche but recruitment is a
rollercoaster right you know it's
especially contracts it really is so
you're going to get ups you're going to
get more downs and ups hundred percent
um but it's it's the way you you learn
from that and how you take that
experience and and use it to your
ability
um but yeah i think luckily i had good
support and and luckily i managed to get
my mindset in the right place now i
appreciate you sharing that like yeah it
wasn't an overnight thing and it was a
week and then so it sounds like i was
going to ask you what would be if
someone listened listen to this right
now is going through that
what you would advise their first step
to be but it seems like get out of your
head and then get back to the things
that you can control which is what's my
plan what i'm gonna do and those things
right so i guess i'd be interested to
hear
like with it happening happening a
second time
obviously that's hard but you've now got
something to point to as to i got out of
it once i can do it again
so
how did you did you do anything
different in terms of
to stop yourself from not like not being
about it for a week like did you handle
it how did you handle it different yeah
i was having this conversation when the
boys in the office the other day because
sometimes they ask me okay like how'd
you do this like getting advice from me
and then
and one of the boys was getting a bit
down about because you know you weren't
getting on jobs things were dropping out
and he weren't he went working for him
and he was kind of asking me like
what's your advice what'd you do and um
it was quite weird i i got to a point
where i kind of
saw recruitment as a game
i see it quite emotional about it like i
got really angry really fuming about it
and i just really got let it affect me
and play my emotions when things won't
go in my way
but then
when you've been in this industry a long
time
you sort of
laugh about it because it's like it
happens you know it's cliche things
always drop out
you know
there's always kind of mad reasons why
things don't work and when you've been
in injury a long time you kind of notice
there's a pattern and you start to
realize these things happen
they're out of your control most of the
time
and you've got to get on with it and i
think once my mentality sort of change
of like look this is a game it goes
you're going to get wins you're going to
get losses
it's about learning from it and moving
forward because if everyone was getting
wins and everyone was doing well
everyone would be millionaires
and i sort of told myself this is a test
you know this is a test against you not
doing well this is a test to sort of
prove right do you really want it do you
deserve it this is gonna happen and when
i sort of told myself these are these
tests to prove you know do you really
want it are you gonna succeed once i got
the mentality i thought okay sweet this
is fine
learn from it this is just a test move
on from it and took the emotions out of
it it sounds like certain emotions that
you have to you have to because
it's an emotional job if you if you lit
this this job is like i said before this
is a you need a strong mentality and if
you've not got a strong head on your
shoulders this job will destroy you 100
because there are so many ups and downs
and you need to cope with that and i
think once you get into a mindset of
this is the game this is the industry
just flow with it once you get in that
mindset things become a lot easier and
you've got a much more clear head to
move on from things generally like
mantras that you live by nice things
like people like these things like we go
again
no one's dying
yeah like i'm not like i know there's a
lot of people are into like meditation
affirmations and things like that i'm
not really into that kind of do you have
like a saying when it's like right boys
we go again we should be knocked back
it's fine if you don't but it seems like
a lot of people do yeah a lot of me look
[ __ ] happens right
it's like it sounds like it is sales
it's the way of the world um
again i just tell myself like this is a
test whenever i get something that's
difficult i just tell myself
this is a test
to prove that are you hungry enough
do you want it and do you deserve it and
that's what i tell myself every single
situation i get into it's a good way to
frame that way so i guess just just so
on this then and then we'll go into like
yeah your journey at the company and
then also some of the things that you
think you've really had to master and
has impacted on your success but
again we've got the benefit of hindsight
now yep so you've had that happen twice
is there anything that you've sort of
taken from those experiences where your
contract work is massively reduced
obviously sometimes a big part of it can
be stuff outside of your control but is
there anything that you really keep a
close eye to now that could be markers
or indicators of
wow okay i've just found out that
information or i've just heard this or
i've seen this happen over the last
couple of weeks
i'm a bit concerned here that my book
could be quite vulnerable yeah what
would have ended up being some of the
markers and things that you've you've
taken from those experiences if if any
yeah
so one of my biggest things was
complacency wow i got really complacent
um because
when you are doing well
the money's rolling in the deals are
rolling in and the job becomes easy it's
very
easy to be like right
cool sit back relax you know this is
just it's flowing um and then you start
missing the basics
small things like catch up with your
contractors on a regular basis you know
if your eyes he's been working there six
months he's all right and you get uh
don't worry about it your client yeah
you know they'll come to me when when
they need someone
um and
it's so key about caring
about your business because as a
contract recruiter even a permanent
recruiter you know you've got your own
desk you're running the business and if
you don't care about your business
things will fall through and i think
with me i got so complacent sometimes
i'd miss out on things for example
i'd have clients where you know
i think oh they'll reach out to me when
they need me and then
i'll catch up with them in a couple of
months time and be like oh i was having
a catch-up oh yeah we hired two people
last month
and it's like that's business i missed
out on because i was being complacent um
one of my contracts is assuming that
he's happy he might have some personal
issues or he might be unhappy with his
manager and me not having to catch up
with him
is could affecting him leaving and i
don't know about it so
i think being complacent is one of the
biggest killers in contract recruitment
especially when you're a higher biller
and i think i had numerous conversations
with jamie about it because he realized
it don't get complacent and he kept me
on the ball and making sure that i'm
doing all the small things all the
basics to make sure i can continue to
grow hey everyone a real quick one from
me this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincerie and sourcebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you were able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with sourcebreaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out sourcebreaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products
appreciate you sharing that last yeah so
so what so i guess she's touching on
that i think that'd be really helpful
people
and i i have heard that a lot
complacency right
so
what what are some of the things that
you do now then that you feel besides
jamie maybe letting you know that may i
think you're getting a bit complacent
here like what are some of the things
that you've now incorporated in your day
on a weekly basis or things that you
tell yourself and do that you feel can
sort of um yeah weed out that
complacency or stop that complacency
from growing is there anything that you
sort of have done or yeah added to your
game that you think has a sort of just
yeah stop that from growing
yeah i think ex
experiences have definitely
impacted me again i've been doing
recruitment eight or nine years now
right so i've i've kind of been through
a lot and i think
the pain of of sort of you know seeing
your book fall down to like over half
overnight and you know
having to build that money back up again
and build up that contract book i think
that's
that is a big pain for me and
the fault of my book like
going overnight is it's a killer and i
think so you remind yourself of that
yeah reminding myself of you know the
graft it put
no one likes a graph right you know
everyone would love to be lazy no one
likes to work hard and graft and i think
knowing that
going back to that okay i've got a graft
i gotta hit the phones and i think
that's again that's what's like i don't
wanna be doing that i'm in a good place
right now i don't wanna be doing the
extra hard hours i'm not going to be
working 14 hour days every week um and
starting over again i think that has
might push me on to
to be on top of things
but i think for me as well is i've
always you know i've always ripped
things down you know all my important
topics i write it down and if it takes
me a month two months three months to
complete it so what as long as i'm
chasing every day and i'm it's there and
i'm knowing it down
that has helped me as well stand on top
of things and
and not being complacent you know even
it's like catch up with john catch up
with him whatever it is it's just small
things like that
to to make sure that you aren't being
lazy and being on on the back foot
that's that the key things i sort of do
really
okay right
so let's get into i think what people be
really keen to hear about is
sort of again taking a step back some of
the things that you think you've had to
do like really well
so i think i i remember taking a note of
this when
we were preparing for this i think this
is sort of an interesting insight so
let's just now sort of focus and talk
about some of the things that you think
have enabled you to be successful beyond
like putting in the graph persistence
people obviously yeah really want to
understand just more of like the
day-to-day what looks like you're like
when we're saying doing the basics
what's that look like but something that
you said to me in preparation for this
was you said one of the things that you
avoid i don't know how long this has
been but you avoid the uk
and the markets you operate and you said
look i do i do business in most
countries not the australian market
because the time zone challenges but you
uh
i don't know how long period but yeah
you avoid the uk and then obviously work
in different parts of the world
talk to me about why why you feel that
why you feel that way about the the uk
market
i feel like that would influence yeah
it's not what it used to be um so when i
started recruitment i was 17 um a while
ago i done the uk market
and
it was a good market because
you know you didn't have ir35 and for
for people that don't know what it is
research it because if you're doing
contract recruitment in the uk you need
to know about because it basically makes
it impossible
to work with contractors in the uk
and make contract deals
um
that was a massive killer i knew i knew
some uk contract billers that had like
15 20k with books and literally when
that policy come out it went to zero
overnight literally um so that killed
the uk market that's a big reason why
and
another reason why is because you've got
more than 45 000 recruitment companies
in the uk
and they all do the uk market
so you've got a lot of competition and
no matter how good you are as a
salesperson what solutions you're
offering
it's hard to compete when you've got a
client who's getting bailed 15 20 times
a day like i agree if you're offering
and your solution is is great but it
makes it very competitive and it's just
not a market i want to work in um
and i think a lot of people watching
this can can agree that the uk market
has lost their golden years it has and
international is the way forward now 100
so uh talk to me about we won't have to
go into all the details but like
thinking of you um achieving the numbers
that you're going to this year like how
diversified is that like is that spread
across like
yeah europe asia these things like what
how how sort of diversified has it ended
up being in order for you to do the sort
of numbers that you've been doing yeah
it's quite diverse to be fair i mean my
majority of my my contractors are across
mainland europe
um but i've got contractors i have got
some contracts in the uk i have it's not
my preference but i have
um it's uk europe
the middle east i've got contracts in
africa
um canada the us and also latin america
so it's really spreading yeah that's
interesting because i think that that
also sort of i think that's good
education for people and their strategy
on how they can grow their contract
books right like you you mentioned a few
different places there which i'm
assuming yeah enables different
opportunities to grow it right rather
than just being
specific to one place yeah definitely so
what i'd love to hear your take on then
uh is like
from your point of view like what what i
don't know it might be one two three
things like what is it that contract
recruiters have to master to to sort of
achieve the sort of things that you've
been able to achieve and will continue
to what is it that you believe they have
to master and we can go granite here
like what is it that people have to
master do you do you think
oh it's hard to sort of pin it down to
like two or three things because i i
there is a bundle of things you need to
sort of master um and it's a long
learning curve
um but going back to what i said in the
beginning um you need to be obsessive
you need you need to be obsessive
because
look if you're happy to come into
recruitment and you earn 50 60 70 80k a
year you know that's fine but you know
you can do that by just probably
plodding along doing the average numbers
you know and just and just just about
hitting target but
if you really want to be the best of the
best and you want to be the best in the
industry you need to be obsessed you
have to be because
you know
you don't get to the top of your game by
being lucky and by being lazy and being
average you really need to be obsessed
of of getting to the top
and
also as well i think you need to sort of
realize that the journey never ends
um i think a lot of people think oh you
know once i get here that's me i'm done
i'm happy um the goal post always moves
and i think you need to be in a
mentality where you understand that you
know in my head i was like okay once i
get to 50k a week that's a good good
target once i've got there i'm like
let's get 60.
now i've got today i'm like let's get to
70. so i think you need to have an
endless appetite i think you need to
just want to achieve and achieve and
achieve
um
and discipline that's that's the key
thing
you know i won't say you need to be good
on the phone you need to be a great
salesman of course it's great it's
important but like i said hard work
beats talent
you need to be disciplined if you if you
have the right mentality and you
you follow the right process and you're
consistent and you stick to it you will
achieve results and i think if you've
got that kind of attitude and that kind
of
focus i think you will be a successful
contract recruiter 100
talking on discipline then people love
this yeah talk to them about your day
plan mate like my day plan yeah like
what like again people people want
granola so like what so right now where
you're at and and the numbers you're
doing like what does
what are the typical day what does
typical day look like for you what are
your non-negotiables when do we start
what we're doing in the morning if
that's something that you believe is
really fundamental to people achieving
their goals let's talk about that i
think it will be really helpful for
people yeah 100 look my
things are different from me now because
you know i'm
i'm kind of in a situation now where i
haven't really got me hitting the phones
anymore you know i've got my clients um
a lot of my stuff comes to me now so i'm
not having to hammer the phone 200 times
a day why don't we do it then when like
you was on the rise right because yeah
that's fair because you've got i can't
remember there's like three or four
people in your team and you're growing
that right yeah sort of delivery
consultants and support you yeah so why
don't we if if you can sort of remember
like on the rise ethan's on the rise i'm
here to make my hungry i mean yeah
because you to get to that point where
you are now you've got your absolute
socks off so rightly so you've got
people coming back to you and then
you've got more space to do other things
develop the team support but yeah talk
to me about yeah ethan on the rise
wanting to absolutely smash it what yeah
what what does that day look like the
fundamentals i was very robotic okay
yeah that's what we want yeah yeah very
right yeah 100 like again this is this
comes down to being going back to the
whole discipline and being obsessed
um
every single day i've done the same
thing day in day out
like structure was on point day plan was
written out what was that literally
you're getting in the morning i'm
checking my emails my linkedin messages
i'm looking at my alerts on linkedin
what time is
um typically back in the day i've got an
eight not anymore getting an rf8 okay i
don't know right it's getting later now
okay so you've got an a yeah so you're
checking in your linkedin emails yeah uh
looking at my linkedin alerts
so i'll go on my linkedin alerts and
that would show me anyone that has
updated their linkedin profile
so i can find out any new projects
they're working on if somebody's gone to
a new company they've changed off okay
right he's gone to that company that's a
new project i can approach
mapping out the market in the morning
looking at posted jobs in the morning
seeing what companies are hiring um
catching up with all my
senior contractors find out where
they're going what the plans are and
then the minute it hit half eight i was
on the phone down five minutes just on
it yeah so the first half an hour in the
morning it was just like getting my day
planned sorted gary on check looking at
all my messages planning and then
halfway it was militant on the phone
what we're doing what bd just being i
was always a bd guy um so halfway until
what when yeah so literally
so in the start of my career it was
split i was you know
halfway until you know half nine talking
to candidates and then i was you know
doing bd from half nine until 12
and then from 1 30 until six clients and
then after that candidates i was
structured like that but then towards
the latter end of my career which is
bdbd that's what i wanted to do um
but i've always been very big on being
on the phone
so
i was always making sure i was dialing
so it's so key that you're not spending
all your time on emails and your
linkedin recruiter you need to be on the
phone 100 so
um having that militant structure of
hits half 8 you're on the phone
that was the key thing for me but yeah i
think um
my structure was very rigid i was always
making sure i was
hitting the targets every day making
sure that my checklist was ticked off i
wouldn't leave that day if my checklist
wasn't ticked off even just small things
like admin tasks i wouldn't leave until
it's done
and having that
robotic mindset
eventually leads up to being successful
did you set yourself like specific goals
if you're doing so much bd and stuff did
you set yourself specific goals and
those times and that in that time period
like would you like right i want to have
like 10 new hiring manager conversations
this period i'm not yeah that's what i'm
aiming for like did you do that or yeah
so the one thing with me like kpis are
very important because it gives you
structure and something to work towards
but i was never really motivated by kpis
because if my kpi was you know i'll talk
to 10 clients i wouldn't get 10 clients
but right okay that's me done for the
day like i was always like okay get to
12 get to 14 get to 15. so
um
yes i had like a something to work
towards of like okay i want to talk to
at least 10 clients a day
that was my focus
but then i wouldn't stop if i got to 10
for example um but yeah it was always
very important having kpis to work
towards and if you're doing if you're
doing that much of it like
what what you do it because i feel like
where a lot of people lose time i'm sure
you see this with your guys and girls is
they can
they they're like right yeah ethan half
eight till 12 i'm going to do bd really
really focused time and sessions and
then you find that they're like
researching and they're like finding the
people they want to call these things
like did you do this sort of pre-bd work
so then when you do go into that time
you you just got people that you know
you want to be sort of trying to get
hold or trying to speak to like did you
do much of that yeah 100 um so i
the way i work i chased a project
so whenever i got news on a hot new
project i was like that's what my target
is so
i mean i think i'd about at one point
about a thousand clients on my
spreadsheet that i would target every
day but then out of those 1000 i'd
probably have about
50 projects where there were new
projects they're big they're higher
contractors and i was like right i've
got to get in there and i would
set aside time to specifically focus on
that
contacting all of the managers emailing
them connects on linkedin leaving
voicemail i was calling like two or
three times a day i was really militant
on on contacting those those particular
projects yeah so you've got the focus
from that so yeah yeah
and then how did you typically get this
information is this through your
candidate network typically yeah there's
a lot of ways um but
with me i would
i would spend an hour
sometimes even two hours every evening
uh mapping out the market
so what i would do i'd go on to linkedin
i would
run a search of my market so i'll do
dynamics so i'd run a search in dynamics
and
i would strip every single profile
on linkedin that has dynamics in their
profile and i would go right okay that
company uses dynamics i note it down and
i would target every single company and
go at them so it all come from my
linkedin projects and my searching um
stripping the cvs
talking to contractors finding out where
they're working that's a key one because
if you're talking to a contractor
and he's told you i'm working for
barclays bank you know that barclays
bank hire contractors
they're running the projects it's in
your market
and that's an angle
and especially you know if it's a
contract you know very well it's an
angle for you to potentially get
introduced by that contractor as well so
i was always big about about talking to
contractors and mapping on linkedin that
was my key thing it's so interesting
that because people probably
see that as super boring but that's
clearly been fundamental to like just
being militant with that and then you
yeah that information is so powerful
yeah i feel like particularly in
contract recruitment obviously perm
recruitment it shows up in different
ways about thinking contract requirement
and chasing those projects if you you've
really got your ear to the ground and
you're doing that that leg work of the
boring market mapping these things but
then you're the first person to get in
on that project and talk to them then
that's that's huge right yeah look like
the the first two three years of in your
career you need to do the dog work if
you do the dog work in the first two to
three years it will set up your career
100 um
so in the early days i was there till
like half 7 8 8 30 at night just mapping
the market stripping all the projects so
then adding all my spreadsheets and when
i come in the next day i can just hit
the phone and i can just smash through
it and that was a key thing for me for
for building up my numbers and as
reaching as many clients as possible
so as we come towards the end here then
mate talk to me about obviously you've
been on this um
i was catching up with a friend the
other night he's been on a sort of
similar journey where when we first met
there was like 11 people in the
recruitment company worked for now yeah
they're getting close to 100.
obviously you as jamie's first hire was
started in a small office in loudoun usa
yeah and obviously yeah where you guys
are now office in miami like what
what uh what's that journey been like
like
what has it been like to be part of a
i'll come like that because i know you
guys haven't you guys from wherever i
take it externally looking in
like and the way that you're talking
today you're not settling you're not
getting complacent so like what what
what's it been like to be part of
because i'm sure jamie sat down and got
look this is where we're going it's big
and it's sort of actually manifested and
you're on your way what's that actually
been like
it's mad because literally our first
office you could just put your arms out
and touch the walls it was literally it
was tiny it was literally me and jamie
in his tiny office and
from day one like we've always
had this vision and spoke about the
vision of where the company's gonna go
to um and
seeing it happen is crazy because you
know
you've got two young essex lads in a
small office
grafton away and then
fast forward six years
we've got 100-plus man office in london
got an office in miami it's growing
crazy it's growing really fast
and
being part of that journey and and
seeing the company change and evolve and
and adapt that it has been crazy um
scary but it's exciting at the same time
but you know it's it's moving in the
right direction and
everything we've said we're gonna we're
gonna do
we've done it plus more
so
it's it's i'm very confident that
everything we're gonna set out today
we're gonna achieve because we've
already done it with flying colours so
hard work all the things you've spoken
about today
definitely doing that and and you're
obviously making sure that you people
have that but
taking a bit of a step back what do you
think has been some of the the key
ingredients to the recipe of like this
company really yeah kicking on and doing
well because i think a lot of
recruitment companies will say this is
where we want to be in six years yeah
not as many get there so like from your
perspective
uh
like taking a step back what do you
think of being some of the key
ingredients that maybe uh yeah jamie's
really tried to cultivate the culture or
has sort of manifested in your culture
what do you think those are it's
definitely been the people 100
um
it's you know culture isn't built by one
person it's built by a team and
everyone that we've we've hired they buy
into us they buy into the company they
buy into the brand and especially the
people that have been there you know the
last few years or so
they they can see where the company's
going and they believe it so
i think the
the reason why we are where we are today
is of course the people um we all
believe the vision we believe where
we're going um you know we've had
the best training you can probably get
in the industry everyone is learning
the proper way how to do recruitment we
learn how to sell sell solutions um and
the marketing of the business has been
very key as well
so
i think it's been down to obviously a
lot of sacrifice and discipline as well
um we've got one of the hardest working
salesforce in london i genuinely believe
that you know that the graph that the
boys put in on a daily basis is second
to none um and i think
when you've got a culture where everyone
wants to earn money and do well
it's hard to find that if you go to a
recruitment company in london like you
might get the odds you know one or two
guys in the office are billing like 10k
a week 15k a week like we've got 10 plus
people are billing 10 15 pushing 20k a
week you don't really see that in
recruitment so everyone is super hungry
and everyone's got the appetite to do
well and when you've got a group of
people
with the appetite and hunger to succeed
it's a dangerous thing
so look uh what like i'd love to just
just sort of end on this really
people counted you out you wasn't sure
what you're gonna do
um you've worked extremely hard to get
to where you you've got to still young
right and i think this is one of the
amazing things about our industry yeah
like anyone maybe who knew um
the teenager years could have easily
said i'm not sure where he's gonna end
up right
why do you think more young people
should choose
a career in recruitment like i really
i'm really passionate about that i think
a criminal recruitment can help so many
people in so many different ways
massively um beyond even staying in the
industry in terms of the skills it
equips you with and those things yeah
it's like what's your view in that
considering the journey you've been on
why should more young people choose
our industry to work in them and choose
it as a career
i think um
recruitment
genuinely gives people the keys to
really like change their life
in many ways it can make you
obviously a lot wealthier that's the key
thing um it can actually give you a
steady career progression you know you
can go
in so many different directions in
recruitment so you can get a strong
career
you know you're going to be an
environment where you actually want to
go to work in the morning you're going
to be around good people
and you're going to be in a situation
where
you're going to
fast track your career because
there's by the time people in my school
were coming out of uni i was already
making six figures and i was already
like in a senior position in my company
um
what other industry can you think of
where you've got 18 19 20 21 year olds
that are owning good money you know
they're senior in the business they're
respected
it's hard to find that um and i think
especially in my case where i come from
a background where
i wasn't very academic i had no interest
in school going to uni going to college
there's thousands of kids out there that
are in the same position as me when i
was a kid where you don't really know
where to go don't know what to do you
know there isn't really a lot out there
in terms of guidance to to what you can
do after leaving school because the
system ain't really
the way the system is in school is like
you go to sixth form you go college you
go une you get a professional job in the
city and that's it um but with
recruitment it really gives you the key
to to really put it all to one side you
know you use your your genuine passion
your hunger your discipline
all those core fundamental sort of
skills that you can be born with and you
can really apply that to recruitment and
really make sense of yourself and that's
why i think recruitment is such an
amazing industry for young people love
it ethan has been absolute pleasure
kudos to you mate really enjoyed that
thank you appreciate it thank you very
much
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode